but first it's my orwellian free speech
brain dump
well george orwell knew a thing or two
about free speech you could fill a book
with sensible things he had to say about
it this quote especially resonates today
in any given moment there is an
orthodoxy he wrote a body of ideas of
which is assumed that all right thinking
people will accept without question it's
not exactly forbidden to say this that
or the other but it's not done to say it
well incredibly things have got a great
deal worse since orwell wrote that
because it is indeed not forbidden to
say this that or the other and the
orthodoxy today is the draconian
illiberal worldview stamped on public
life by woke fundamentalist this council
culture mob said all the rules trampling
over our rights to free speech in the
process and anyone who doesn't conform
is instantly slammed silenced and shamed
and much of it is of course politically
motivated that's why former president
trump is barred from twitter even though
74 million people voted for him in a
democratic election but vladimir putin
the supreme leader of iran and the
taliban are all still free to tweet this
is obviously utterly ridiculous now the
billionaire maverick of free speech
absolutist elon musk who's about to buy
twitter says that the ban is morally
wrong and he will reverse it and he's
been supported by jack dorsey one of the
founders of twitter
trump told me he doesn't actually want
to return to twitter even if he's
allowed to but i reckon you'll change
his mind about that and the point is it
should be his decision
liberals have reacted with an inferno of
rage and panic as they always do
everything ever since musk said he'd
restore free speech and trump to the
platform
london may sadiq khan today blamed trump
for a massive spike in abuse he got
online but even he says he's open to
trump returning but he qualified it by
adding let's wait and see if donald
trump has learned his lesson if it's the
case i think that's all well and good if
he breaks the rules there need to be
consequences well that's fine words but
there's the number of the problem who
decides what those rules are which are
to be broken
all racist abuse is wrong and so is any
incitement to violence but both of those
things are already illegal free speech
doesn't mean you can break the law nor
does it mean you have to continue
listening to somebody who's spewing
something vile that you don't like
to illustrate that sports presenter eli
baba has written today about how she
dealt with completely unacceptable
homophobic and racist comments made
during an afternoon speech at a scottish
sports awards at the weekend she didn't
demand the speed to be cancelled but she
did exercise her right to walk out and
she exercised her right to free speech
to call it out on twitter and that was
right
believe me and this may shock you people
do say nasty things about me all the
time on the internet i don't want to
cancel them but i do sometimes block
them or call them utter morons that too
is an exercising of my right to free
speech
one of the biggest problems of twitter
is that many people on it don't seem to
have any sense of humor my fiery
interview with the taliban official
spokesman last night got everyone
talking and twitter of course whipped
itself into a frothy lather of rage
about them in fact i was even doing it
one woman named laura tweeted comedian
ricky gervais always a bad idea to say
what do you think about piers morgan
interviewing the taliban tonight and she
added the hashtag disgusting
or gervais replied like this
i've lost all respect for them
[Laughter]
i've had to add the canned laughter so
that any wokies watching realized he was
joking
but not everyone knew this so you mean
you've had respect for them was one
reply to gervais
i thought you claimed to be an advocate
for free speech said another no you're
backtracking on people just because they
want to air an opinion you don't like
incredibly even the daily mirror a
national newspaper i used to run
failed to get the joke
ricky gervais slams piers morgan for
disgusting taliban interview it raged
no he didn't
no it wasn't
he was joking obviously but obviously
not
otherwise he would have got the joke
it took another british comedian david
badil to point out the bleeding obvious
this
is a great joke he tweeted that's it
that was it it was a funny joke
that was off the back of an incredibly
serious sobering subject but we must
never let serious things in the world
mean we lose our sense of humor
unfortunately jokes are increasingly an
endangered species in today's miserable
order of a world where being mortally
offended and outraged is very much in
fashion the joyless woke brigader so
desperate to feel aggrieved
affronted
[Music]
and appalled
to which i remind them all of the advice
from the late great cricket genius shane
warne
and in this politically correct day and
age we just got to be a little bit
careful but sometimes
just say get stuff to the fun police
i mean seriously just tell me get
stuffed
nobody puts always better than the man
who got me into all this mess last night
mr gervais
there's gonna be a bit of that
throughout the show see if you can spot
it okay now
that's when i say something i don't
really mean for comic effect and you as
an audience you laugh at the wrong thing
because you know what the right thing is
it's a way of satirizing attitudes like
that first joke i use the old-fashioned
sexist trope that women aren't funny now
in real life i know there are loads of
funny women like um
i did it again well spotted good
even as that clip ends i know there are
people tweeting me incensed wokies
who don't get the joke or perhaps they
do get it but pretend not to so they can
virtually signal their mock outrage
it and they
are exhausting
well as he's tiresome woke his whale
about trump being unbanned from twitter
and halfway excuses for journalists
failed the irony test and would have
failed my employment test if i was still
at the mirror real free speech champions
are putting their lives on the line for
the truth every single day
palestinian reporter sharin abu aklay
was shot and killed today while covering
an israeli raid in the west bank the al
jazeera correspondent is also a u.s
citizen was hugely respected she's
reported for decades on flash points in
israel and palestine bravely crossing
between both sides report uncomfortable
truths about a complex and emotive
conflict she was wearing a press badge
journalists like shireen are the reason
why we understand the world george
orwell himself wrote vividly about the
spanish civil war a free press is the
reason we know that putin is a genocidal
war criminal while millions have
brainwashed russians in a country where
journalists get murdered for their job
think he's saving ukraine from nazis
several journalists have already been
killed in ukraine covering the war many
others are out there right now risking
their lives to bring us that truth
now you might be tempted to think that a
free press can be taken for granted in
2022 but it can't
the facts show it's in decline it's time
we began fighting much harder for him
more and more countries are ganging
reporters many use a pandemic as an
excuse to muzzle journalists on the
bogus pretext of protecting public
health and according to unesco a
staggering 85 percent of the world's
population lives in a place where press
freedom has been restricted in the last
five years
and ironically by their own measure
the last time press freedom plummeted to
these deaths was 1984 the very title of
george orwell's iconic novel
well newspeak was of course the name of
a dystopian language in george orwell's
1984 it was a controlled and contorted
vocabulary designed to limit people's
ability to think for themselves well
besides being a free speech champion
orwell had a big imagination but i doubt
even he would have believed that
newspeak is now being imposed on british
doctors and nurses
first maternity services were ordered to
use gender inclusive terms like chest
feeding for new mothers to avoid
upsetting trans patients
to which i say well what about the upset
caused to women who want to identify as
women and be called women and mothers
and who want to be told they're
breastfeeding
what are their rights
well now nhs bosses are being lectured
on the danger of microaggressions which
is one of my least favorite words in the
whole english language apparently these
can be worse than overt acts of hate and
could cause ptsd post traumatic stress
disorder
what
what does that even mean
people have literally have to deal every
day with patients suffering very real
ptsd from life-threatening illness or
terrible injuries i've now got to watch
their words in case it sends perfectly
healthy people into a spiral of trauma
when did we get so pathetic
why did we get so pathetic
i grew up in a world where the usual
advice offered to anyone who overreacted
to hurtful words with sticks and stones
may break my bones but words will never
hurt me
i kind of miss that world
well coming up how do we save afghan
women from the taliban wall should trump
be allowed to tweet again china's zero
coven nightmare and one of the funniest
men in america greg gutfeld is live all
coming up all uncensored
[Music]